another day another set of difficulties
are you failing families on the cost of
living prime minister this a crisis he
can't wave away
entering the chamber as the country
enters a cost of living crunch a pm
under pressure and his opponents keen to
capitalize he's an ostrich
perfectly happy keeping his head in the
sand
working people are worried about paying
their bills
working people are looking for help but
this week
millions will look at their pay slip and
see a tax rise with his fingerprints all
over it
in disagreement and on the defensive
making his pitch to voters what we're
doing for working people is not only
lifting the living wage by the by the
record amount uh helping people on
universal credit within a thousand pound
tax cut mr speaker but also cutting uh
national insurance contributions
problems mounting as is the workload as
questions keep coming over how to help
families feel in the pinch what is the
prime minister going to do to ensure
that all of our constituents have a
right to light and towards if the
supermarkets are stepping in to protect
people's pockets
what will the prime minister do
much of what mr johnson can do depends
on this man his chancellor who went on
mumsnet today to take questions on food
prices fixed penalty notices and
financial struggles we'll see what
happens and then depending on what
happens to bills then of course if we
need to act and provide support for
people we will i've always said that but
it would be silly to do that now or last
month or the month before when we don't
know exactly what the situation in the
autumn is going to be
autumn a long way away for those already
suffering in cities like wolverhampton
people feeling the squeeze as prices
shoot up my biggest complaint at the
minute
is um you know the electric and gas yeah
and um
well food and things like that the
necessary things what we all need seems
to have shutted off how are you finding
life at the moment in terms of
the cost of living in your bills and
everything how are things struggling
anything else
also a struggle taking over this
business in the midst of a pandemic
that's ten pound exactly please lindsay
says brooke's coffee house only survived
because of her loyal regular customers
who she's now loathed to repay with
price rises how have you felt as a
business owner have you noticed it in
terms of
literally everything's gone up we had no
menu so um this costs a lot of money
so
we haven't changed our prices as yet but
it's going to be something we might have
to look at so it's hard for you because
you don't want to change your prices
because you have regular customers and
they're not going to want prices to go
up but your costs are going up so your
margins are good yeah squeezed right
yeah it's going to be something we'll
have to look at okay so you think you
might have to put the prices up at some
point yeah
wolverhampton home to a brick in the
conservatives hard won red wall here
addressing the cost of living really
matters if the government hoped to avoid
a squeeze on its own majority bathrigby
sky news in wolverhampton